[Musique]
notre histoire commence
il y a environ cent mille ans avec la
présence de petits groupes d'hommes de
néanderthal éparpillés dans toute
l'europe
c'était un genre d'hommes différents
mais ils disparu lors de l'arrivée de
populations de cro magnon nos ancêtres
directs
[Musique]
les hommes de cro magnon chasser les
rênes et les bisons vivaient dans des
huttes rondes qu'il protégeait par des
palissades et bien que primitif
ils ont laissé les décorations de
grottes qui nous émerveille encore elles
sont reconnues comme les premiers
chef-d'oeuvre au monde nous sommes à la
fin des grandes glaciations
les hommes se sédentarisent et se
réunissant en petit village composé de
maisons de bois
il commence à développer l'agriculture
l'élevage la céramique et la culture du
lin pour en faire des tissus
[Musique]
suivant le culte des astres ils
construisent des normes temple
mégalithique pour calculer les cycles de
la nature
[Musique]
ce n'est qu'au début de l'âge du bronze
que se forment les premiers grands
peuples européens dont les plus
puissants sont les ibères les ligures et
les das un millénaire plus tard d'autres
peuples deviennent tout aussi important
ce sont les étrusques les grecs les
carthaginois les germains les bretons et
les salles
[Musique]
les celtes peuples indo européens
provenant d'au delà du danube avait la
renommée d'être riche et courageuse les
sépultures de leroy témoigne d'un art
frais raffiné et leur culte prêchée par
les druides était celui de la
transmigration de l'âme une sorte d'
équilibre régnait alors entre les
frontières mais il se troubla au début
de l'âge du fer pour coloniser la
méditerranée des marins grecs avaient
envahi les côtes italique et ibérie
d'autres grecs
les phocéens débarqué tôt bouches du
rhône pour y fonder plusieurs cités dont
massilia qui devint la marseille actuel
devant cette invasion les ibères les
celtes et surtout les ligures qui
contrôlait le territoire attaquèrent les
phocéens mais massilia était puissante
elle écrase les ligures et leur enlève
une citadelle qu'elle appellera nice
comme la déesse grecque de la victoire
en europe entre temps les invasions
continuer les carthaginois avait annexé
les terres des ibères tandis que les
germains à la recherche d'un climat plus
tempéré avaient envahi en masse les
terres des seuls et ce fut le chaos
la poussée des germains fut si rude de
certains peuples celtes s'enfuir sur les
terres des bretons d'autres furent
repoussés vers la péninsule ibérique
vers les terres des et russes le danube
ou encore en gaulle où ils seront
appelés gaulois
les celtes gaulois une centaine de
peuple souvent en conflit entre eux avec
une forteresse les oppida grâce à leur
formidable cavalerie guerrière ils
faisaient des incursions et les gaulois
c'est non havas germaine rome à cette
époque une modeste citadelle cela donna
probablement un tournant à l'histoire
car rome saccagé voulu se venger elle
forma alors une redoutable armée écrasa
les et russe un ex à la péninsule
italique et envahit les territoires en
deçà des alv les nommant gaule cisalpine
les gaulois saliens et arverne alarmé
par l'avancée romaine et des râleurs les
carthaginois d'hannibal lors de son
invasion de litanies mais la république
romaine bien qu'attaqué sur ses propres
terres était devenu une véritable
machine de guerre elle contre attaque a
bâti les troupes danival et efface à
carthage pour toujours puis pour
contrôler la méditerranée occupa la
péninsule ibérique et la grèce
s'arrêtant menaçante aux frontières de
la gaule les riches gaulois et 2 1 tout
comme marseille préférèrent s'allier à
rome plutôt que la combattre
l'esa lien au contraire or mr d'une
coalition et attaquèrent marseille rome
elle n'attendait que ça
ces légions passèrent alors les alpes
écrasèrent la coalition gauloise et sur
les territoires soumis fondèrent la
gaule narbonnaise
les troubles des gaulois cependant
n'était pas terminée des centaines de
milliers de germain suèves en
envahissant la gaule poussé les helvètes
à envahir les terres des et de un ami de
rome rome intervint encore et c'est le
proconsul jules césar qui fut chargé de
la mission à la tête de ses légions
césar rentrer dont en gaule et 20 les
helvètes
puis il va aussi les cela elle
s'installe sur les terres conquises et
propose aux gaulois de se joindre à la
république romaine pour s'opposer
ensemble aux incursions des germains
les gaulois préoccupé par la présence
des troupes romaines sur leurs terres
refusèrent au contraire ils appelèrent à
l'aide
les belges et celtes germaniser mais
césar était invincible
il va même les belgique et profitant des
mésententes entre les gaulois il
conquiert l'ensemble de la gaule
l'allemand gaulle transalpine
les gaulois pourtant ne s'avouaient
toujours pas vaincu mis de côté leurs
anciens différents ils avaient réuni
leurs forces pour affronter
l'envahisseur commun et c'est un jeune
chef arverne appelé vercingétorix guy
pris le commandement de la coalition au
cours des premiers combats
césar est battu mais il regroupe alors
ses forces contre attaque brûle les
terres des gaulois et assiégeant
vercingétorix à alésia
il met fin à la rébellion
césar écrira dans son commentaire sur la
guerre des gaules avoir triomphé sur le
terror galy kum
mais à son retour à rome césar est
assassiné s'ouvre alors une lutte
terrible pour le pouvoir qui se termine
quand octavien auguste neveu de césar
écrase les conjurés et se fait couronner
empereur par le sénat
c'est l' empire romain
pour mieux contrôler la gaule
transalpine octavien auguste la divise
en gaule lyonnaise aquitaine et belgique
toutefois les gaulois n'étaient pas tous
soumis
bien que prenant la citoyenneté romaine
et accédant au sénat certains d'entre
eux voulurent encore se rebeller rome
les rep lima alors si durement que la
gaule entière dû accepter la paix
romaine
c'était une paix armée mais la
supériorité militaire de lempire
permettait aux commerces de se
développer en toute tranquillité rome
continue ses conquêtes sur l'île
britannique et annexes les terres ddas
pourtant salon de paix devait trouver sa
fin
[Musique]
arrivant d'asie des hordes de mon bol un
et deux turcs
alain dévasté tout sur leur passage il
pénètre même dans les terres des
germains refoulant légaux vers la mer
noire et les francs les alamans et les
burgondes vers les terres des gaulois
c'est à nouveau le cas où les frontières
de l' empire sont renversés rome réagi
alors cette coupe
pat les francs les confinant au nord
puis elle va aussi les alamans les
repoussant vers le rhin
mais la situation n'est plus contrôlable
l' empire romain est trop étendu pour
être bien défendu il est alors divisé en
deux
[Musique]
l'empiré romain d'occident avec pour
capitale mediolanum l'actuel milan rome
étant devenu un centre religieux
chrétiens et l'empiré romain d'orient
avec byzance pour capitale
[Musique]
cependant affaiblie par les germains
l'empiré romain d'occident doit aussitôt
abandonné l'île britannique aux saxons
en gaule ils recrutent les alains dans
son armée et à singo burgondes un large
territoire angolais lyonnaise met la
pression d un d'attila ne donnait pas de
répit aux germains les suez et les
vandales refoulé en gaule la traverse
pour enfin s'établir en espagne et en
afrique tandis que les airs hull poussé
en italie la saccagent en déposant
l'empereur romain d'occident pour homme
symbole de la chrétienté
c'était la fin
mais byzance s'opposent ils s'accordent
avec le prestigieux peuple d'ego qui
transitaient sur son empire et leur
donne la tâche de libérer l'italie
en échange ils auront des territoires en
dole lego se remirent d'eau en marche
est arrivé en italie
il écrase r les airs hull puis il se
divisait en deux peuples les wisigoths
qui joint aux dernières troupes romaines
ont chassé les uns
pour enfin s'installer en aquitaine et
les ostrogoths qui occupèrent l'italie
désobéissant aux ordres de byzance
tandis que les uns en fuite poussait les
slaves à envahir les plaines de l'est
la gaule rempli deux royaumes barbares
qui se faisaient la guerre entre eux
devenait d'air de conquête et c'est
childéric premiers rois mérovingiens des
francs saliens qui attaquent en premier
et annexes les territoires limitrophes
son fils clovis plus ambitieux s'élance
de tournai pour conquérir l'ensemble de
la gauche les francs était alors
puissant le vis pas et annexes le
dernier bastion romain en gaule pas les
burgondes et s'allie avec eux bah les
wisigoths les repoussant en espagne mu
il bat même les alamans étant dans son
royaume
jusqu'à la haute rhénanie
enfin conscients de la force d'union de
l'église
il se fait baptiser chrétiens obtenant
le titre d'auguste par le pape
clovis premier roi de l'ancienne france
établi sa capitale à paris et ses fils
annexe la burgondes mais leurs héritiers
diviseront le pays en trois grands
royaumes francs la neustrie l'austrasie
et la bourgogne
tandis que les byzantins chassait les
ostrogoths de l'italie les ans se
battait contre les gascons les bretons
les germains lombard et même entre eux
car clotaire ii de neustrie annexa
l'austrasie sous dagobert derniers rois
mérovingiens le royaume franc se
reconstitue à quoi que l'aquitaine s'en
détache à en proclamant son indépendance
en espagne le royaume wisigoth vivait
son apogée
mais en france la couronne des francs
devenait toujours plus faible c'est la
période des rois fainéants les maires du
palais font les seigneurs et l'un
d'entre eux leduc d'austrasie charles
martel arrive même à enfermer le roi
childéric 3 dans un monastère
puis il conquiert la neustrie la
bourgogne des actuels austriche bavière
du pays bas devenant le vassal le plus
puissant du royaume franc
en europe entre temps un nouveau grand
danger approche les armes et d'une
nouvelle fois l'islam
après avoir conquis des possessions
orientale de l'empiré byzantin avance
vers les balkans
mais ils sont repoussés par les bulgares
il passe alors par l'afrique envahissent
la péninsule ibérique et écrase les
wisigoths ce sont les musulmans
il serait rentré en france si le duc
d'aquitaine ne les avait combattu et si
charles martel ne les avaient pas
arrêtée à poitiers les repoussant
l'espagne
à charles martel succédèrent ses fils
car le mans et pépin le bref mais comme
car le mans choisi la vie monastique
pépin resta seul au pouvoir il déposa
alors définitivement childéric 3 et se
proclama roi des francs à sa place
mais sa couronne n'était pas légitime
il avait besoin de l'église est
l'occasion se présenta avec une invasion
des lombards
à rome le pape
étienne deux appels à l'aide pépin le
bref qui rentre alors en italique et bas
les lombards en récompense il est sacré
unique et légitime roi des francs